college football has targeting the NFL
does not if I have targeting in the NFL
what would be the downside to that I
don't think there is a downside unless
you adopt the college rule as it is
because the college rule as it is is too
ambiguous there's no there's no area
between targeting and unnecessary
roughness so if there's any contact of
the head or neck area really even if
it's not egregious it gets called
targeting and the stage targeting and
the kid is out I am a bit mystified as i
think back at it that college really
protects their players more than the NFL
does just from this targeting rule and i
have said recently and especially after
thursday night i do think that it's
getting to the point where penalty yards
and money is not deterring the act you
know and so if you could say if you
could give me a targeting rule in the
NFL that makes it a type 1 target so
it's the Brandon Marshall hit it's that
it's the hit the other hit that they had
those two vicious helmet-to-helmet hits
if you could make them reviewable in
replay and let them confirm that it in
fact is a type one play grant hit then I
think you not only eject the player but
if they're like Stuart's hit at the end
of the game you do like college he's out
for the first half of the next game yeah
you gotta do something to put some teeth
in it and I think when you're talking a
46 man roster and you take a player away
of a 46 man roster I mean colleges might
have 80 to 100 but the NFL that's a big
deterrent to me and if you if you're
going to take you out of the game so I I
agree totally with you that they need to
get this aspect of the rule change to
where you can take the egregious act and
get them off the field Mike if I'm a
defensive player I have no problem
hitting you in the head and getting 15
yards even a 23 thousand dollar fine
that's not a big deal all right but if
you take me off the field now I've hurt
my team a game check
now all of a sudden that resonates and
you can also have these guys go back to
this is how you have to tackle there's
no deterrent for me to go in or Cam
Newton and you're not just trying to
attack the player here and the league
hasn't been you know doing that they
want to they want to attack the coaches
here and make sure it's being coached
the right way and make sure the coaches
are telling them not to lead but their
helmet and not to go headhunting like
that you know hey listen maybe it
affects the the 15 yards affects the
coaches more but to me it just hasn't
shown as enough of a deterrent to keep
it from doing it I mean they're trying
to get the defenders to lower the target
area and I know it's tough but to me in
both of the situation with Marshall and
Stewart I think it is they could have
gone lower it could have wrapped and
tackled and they they tried to punish
and instead of trying to make the play
and i think that the league needs to
react to that what about trying to get
rid of or lemonade or water down the
kickoff wait what is this backfiring on
the league well i think it's too hard to
tell I mean you know look at it's
obvious that they want less returns
which is a complete turnaround from six
or seven years ago when they wanted more
returns when they were concerned about
the number of touchbacks so and we know
that you have the type of contact in
kickoff situations where two guys are
running directly at each other and the
concussion rate you know / number of
kickoffs is hi there but you can't get
rid of it I mean are you going to get
rid of the kick up you can't you can't
give up on the element of an onside kick
because if you do a team that's down
three scores in the fourth quarter it's
done and and I don't think you can say
well you know if you want to onside kick
will give you the opportunity you can
elect to do so then that takes away the
surprise onside kick you know and we've
seen those in Super Bowls that is worth
so I I think that they've got to keep
trying to search for ways to reduce the
number of injuries and like in my
opinion for example why why is it not so
much an emphasis on punts it's kickoffs
well why because basically the receiving
team lines up on the line of scrimmage
very
close to the line of scrimmage and they
don't retreat until after the ball is
kicked so make the receiving team put
nine guys in a box up by where the ball
is kicked and so then any kicking teams
running down receiving teams you know
retreating that's why there aren't as
many injuries on the punt game so try
that I mean try that my gosh you'll even
get greater returns with everybody up
there further return so the league which
likes offense anyways would be happy
about that aspect the book got some
publicity because of your run-in with
Roger Goodell before he was the
Commissioner now did you were you
concerned about putting that in with the
commissioner yes um I was her but I
wasn't hearing from him before so I
there's no reason for me to hear about
him somebody said somebody wrote me a
sent me an email is said you know don't
expect the christmas card from well i
haven't got one of hitting here so i'm
not i'm not overly concerned about it it
was it was an example of two real
stubborn guys I mean it was the incident
with bottle gate in cleveland or Terry
McAulay took the teams off the field
with 43 seconds to go and said game over
because they were getting belted by
bottles some half full some I think
totally full probably any human would do
that take the team off the field and say
we're getting beat up by bottles games
over he doesn't have the authority to do
that we had to bring the teams back on
the field for to kneel down plays which
was really kind of nonsensical to me but
nevertheless we did and you know what do
I do with macaulay who ended the game
when he wasn't supposed to I did
everything I thought I should do which
was to give him the downgrade for doing
that wrote him a letter but Roger 1 i'm
suspended and and I wasn't going to
suspend him I mean I'm not gonna suspend
the guy for leaving the field when he's
getting hit by beer bottles I mean I'm
not gonna do it and so I mean I was
stubborn in my defense of Macaulay he
was he was stubborn in his defense of
the Cleveland Browns and I know he was
getting a lot of crap from the Cleveland
Browns and so he's defending his side
I'm defending my side it
you know it wasn't the first argument
that we had and I think he got so
frustrated that he gave me the shoved
that tried to get me back into my office
it wasn't assault by any stretch of the
imagination but it was a shove that can
you read on them um if I have Pauly's
step up to play the role of Goodell
listen I can't you reenacted know
because I was bruised for six years
after that you know I don't know you
might you get to knock Paulie oh I do
yes oh can you realize the force money
oh yeah stand up okay all right you
think and take the headphones I got it
we're gonna see how violent this was so
Pauly's playing the role of Mike Pereira
and you're there going toe-to-toe here
and Pereira is oh that's or the flag wow
wow that's his soul Paulie you're gonna
be able to continue to show I want a
flag throwing I want got targeted Paulie
I held my ground for that you just did
though come on that wasn't that hard of
a show could you have taken Goodell
could I have taken them yeah well if I
wanted them to be my last day in the job
then maybe I would have tried no Jesus
he's he's he's he's strong and he likes
to get his way so I think he did
probably coming to me neither pummeled
me at the end of the at the end of the
argument or while I was on the floor
laying facedown like Cam Newton was on
Thursday night alright can you stay of
course all right we'll come back we'll
continue with Mike and if you do have a
question for Mike you have the
opportunity if you like to call us all
right and uh we're gonna act out a
end-zone celebration and I want to know
if you would flag the certain end-zone
celebration okay we have all right so
we're gonna do that if you're watching
on directv the audience network or NBC
sports network seton will reenact some
touchdown celebrations you're ready for
this aren't you c'ton hundred percent
born ready all right uh eight seven
seven three DP show if you have a
question for Mike prayer we're back his
book is upon further review we'll talk a
little bit more about that when we
return on the Dan Patrick show Mike
Pereira from Fox their NFL rules analyst
his book upon further review inside the
infamous controversial and unforgettable
calls to change the NFL available in
bookstores
and online also has a foundation that I
love the concept of this battlefields to
ball field to the program that helps
veterans get started in officiating
careers yeah you know I'm at the last
night with three vets here two guys from
the army one guy who served both in the
Army and the Marines and and that you
know I've always felt and I've talked to
so many vets who when they returned from
their tours of duties they missed the
concept of team and that's their biggest
adjustment not being part of a team so
we've started a foundation Jeff Fisher's
on the board Nate Boyer that you've read
about is on the board so we're taking
these returning vets and we're giving
them full scholarships to become sports
officials in their community and we have
six of them in Southern California who
have started this year under a pilot
program and it is so great to see them
on the field and it's any sport we're
putting them any sport they want to do
it's just so great to see them feel a
part of something like this to be
working with a crew of officials working
with kids on the field and and it really
I've enjoyed writing the book and enjoy
my job I love the foundation I'm a
racist my juices are really flowing
battlefields to ball fields it's a it's
great uh we were talking about how tough
it is to official be an official what
sport would be the toughest uh it is
there a tougher sport to officiate than
the NFL well I would only say this that
when officials would come to me and say
I want to become a better football
official what do you suggest I would say
go work basketball for three years I
think basketballs tougher um you you
have so many decisions that you have to
make in a very small environment and so
much Hampton is it enough is it there's
there's more to me inherent pressure in
basketball than there is in football and
I did a type iteration I did it there is
I did it for three years and it's really
hard it was really hard and that's why
for a while we were taken officials out
of the arena football league and still
do they get some training there because
they work in a closed in environment and
and and i just think basketball to me is
is the hardest my officials hated made
it when i said that you
on the NFL but I do believe that who's
the coach that just chewed your ear off
did you ever about who's the coach that
didn't cheer my to my ear up now did you
ever have somebody really get personal
angry at you well the Mike Shanahan read
me the riot act probably more than any
single coach did in any single play and
the hardest part of it was that I
deserved every single you know that I
was like people saying it's so true
about officiating you never remember
your good call somebody asked an
official you know what's the best call
he ever made and you got and I don't
know what's the worst and boy the worst
for me was the playoff game with Kansas
City in denver in kansas city in the
division championship game in 97 when
early in the game is simple out and up
and the biggest most blatant act of
illegal contact and you know my flag and
my whistle were somewhere down in here i
swallowed him so much and I froze on the
play and I missed it so badly and after
the play was over I knew it in and Mike
was really good on the sidelines when he
wanted to get on somebody and he he got
on me he got on me and I did deserve it
and that was that that was about the
best how about unofficially do can you
tell me you referees ref differently in
the final two minutes well are you
instructed to no sir you don't know you
don't little they say well they're
they're swallowing their whistle I don't
you hear that you I think you hear that
more in basketball than you hear it in
football um I personally feel it this
way that if you officiate the game
different in the fourth quarter or the
last two minutes of the game you're not
being fair to anybody you're not being
fair to the officials you not being fair
of the players or the coaches it's hard
enough to adopt one standard of
officiating much less try to sit through
another standard in the fourth quarter
or the last five minutes and you are
graded and I guess here's the most
relevant point when you are graded and
that's how you keep your job and that's
how you get playoff assignments or Super
Bowl your graded the same in the first
two minutes as you are in the
last two minutes so the last thing you
want to do is get smothered with a bunch
of no calls for not calling something in
the last two minutes so i really believe
at least in football i can't speak for
other sports but i believe it's one of
the myths that are involved in
officiating talking to mike prayer the
book is upon further review inside the
infamous controversial an unforgettable
calls the change the NFL will get a
couple of phone calls here and we have a
can we do a scenario here can i can i'm
going to bring the dance up and we have
a scenario and if you're watching you
can see this we have two scenarios only
okay remember not to sinner's you could
be ejected if they're both pals okay so
dan this is loosely based on the Antonio
Brown catch fumble the other day ooh
we're gonna ask Mike to call it on the
receiver for its ease of the defender
and what does he see okay ready okay
only caught it two feet down Prince he
knocked it out of his hands what would
you call Mike I would call that bang
bang bang that's the terminology we use
bang bang but what's in home in real
time that is so close it is clearly an
incomplete pass you got to get control
you got to get two feet and then you
happen to have an element of time you
had no time it's incomplete all right
really good they fit to play well really
good lie down corner to progress okay
Dan this will be an offshoot of that
okay my ready it's the same one made a
football move but did you hold on to the
well you are you that's not a football
month okay because I mean that was like
him there's nothing athletic about that
whatsoever all right okay here's the
other one you're the official and Seton
is just scored a touchdown and this is
his the celebration back Oh touchdown
there's a little bit of pelvic thrusting
their would you pelvic thrusting as call
to this past weekend pelvic thrusting is
a foul you know we call it around we
call it in the butt that to me which I'm
sold now I hardly remember with this
stuff anymore but is a sexual gyration
and sexual gyrations are not allowed on
the field that is a penalty and a flag
for embarrassing you would you have
called Eli Manning in the grass no in a
Super Bowl no you wouldn't okay mm-hmm
what if they did on that play we'd be
minus one of the great plays in the area
the Super Bowl uh Chris in Seattle your
question for Mike Pereira thanks for
taking my call yep yeah real real quick
like um who are you voting for Donald
Trump or Hillary Clinton no there you go
I can't stand Hillary Clinton you know
thank you Chris thank you Chris well
let's see the way I stand right now I'm
voting for the danettes I think they
would be the yell done and I could be
the best candidate at this point uh yeah
this might be a bad idea but let me try
it again Eric in Florida Eric your
question for Mike prayer hey Dan I good
good great good um miss parole just one
of y'all mr. Pereira anybody that calls
me mr. Pereira I'm so like so flattered
go ahead yes so whichever play that's
currently not available for review for
instant replay would you like to see be
available review for instant replay okay
thank you Eric um III think as we
discussed a little bit earlier I'd like
to see the helmet to helmet hits be
reviewable especially if it involves
ejection which I would like to see it
involved beyond that I don't want to see
any other play reviewable because to me
it already interferes with the game
enough to the legendary George Young
back in nineteen ninety nine when he was
the head of football operations for the
league when we brought back instant
replay he didn't want it and on
little manila folder where his instant
replay folder where you'd write on the
tab instant replay he didn't write
instant replay on the front of it he
wrote the monster grows okay if I gave
the NFL Mulligan no replay or continue
to do what they're doing no I continue
to do what they're doing minus minus any
aspect of judgment judgment doesn't
belong in replay to me facts only and
and this is what in my opinion has
screwed up what is a catch and what is
not a catch because it's a pure judgment
call by the official who calls it based
on how he sees it on the field of the
play it smells like a catch it looks
like a catch but technicality by the
rule it's not its judgment it doesn't
belong I'd take it out that be my
Mulligan he's Mike prayer are Fox NFL
rules analyst the book is after further
review inside the infamous controversy
unforgettable calls to change the NFL
and also his foundation battlefields to
ball fields it's great to see you great
to see you thank you look great your
hair looks great thank you I'd give you
a chance with Goodell I thought you
could go one round maybe hockey Lee
would kick your ass though they'll
ocular yeah he would he don't know he
won yeah he could not he cannot because
I'd never get close enough to him in my
house Abby Wambach will join us in
studio two hours in the book one more to
go dan patrick show the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience